[Music]
okay everybody i am
really really excited today because i am
joined by the one and only
christine sutherland aka you know her
from
buffy as joyce summers but it's really
exciting because today she comes out
with a new film it's an indie rom-com
called before during after and she plays
pat
christine how are you doing today i'm
good hello everybody out there
in zoom land what would we do
i know like this is crazy like i'm in
new york i'm talking to you all the way
across the world
um and yeah and it's cool because i just
got sent your film i watched it i loved
it
and i was wondering for you how did a
part like this even come about
um well we knew finnerty um you know
from just
the world from her work from the theater
from new york
and uh and she just reached out and
asked us if we would be interested in
these uh
two parts and we had never worked
together my husband
and i so it was a wonderful opportunity
and we read the script and we just
were in love with it so we were really
excited to do it
yeah so that's interesting you mentioned
you and your husband are both in this
film and what i thought was
incredible is that you actually play
husband and wife
in the film can you tell me like how
that experience was was that like
surreal
yeah it was because our careers have
been
so separate and so different
years ago i think i was in a dr pepper
commercial and then he
got later got passed to do the voiceover
so
before this that was the only time we
had okay
it was really interesting i mean that it
just seemed
totally natural to go together
you guys in the film get along pretty
well now did that feel like
it was realistic to real life like or
did you guys feel like you had to act a
little different
on screen together no i i think we just
brought
ourselves together to it because it was
it was so it was so right it was so
perfect
for both of us you know yeah no and
it came off great you guys did an
awesome job and
i wonder too because you're you know you
were in honey i shrunk the kids this big
movie you're in this big tv show buffy
can you kind of compare those
experiences to doing like an indie film
like this like
what that was like pros and cons wise
well you know the work is the work and
and and
and so in that sense it's it's all
the same um but i think there's
just sort of this family and and
any production can become a family but
there's a
more of an intimacy more of a sort of
striking out into the unknown what's
gonna happen
with this you know you don't have some
of the assurances
uh feeble insurances that you you have
with a
you know big name production with a lot
of money behind it so
but you know other than that it you know
the crew was fantastic
um so a lot of the new technology um
gosh which is i you know i don't even
know how many years it's been since the
um
what is it the red camera sure right
you know digital uh cameras that will do
really good filming and that's just
changed the whole
world i mean it's fantastic that you
know
everybody can you know that it's it's so
much
more possible for people with stories
to make them and get them out into the
world so we're so excited for finnerty
and for
everybody involved in the project
because i i just think it's a really
fantastic film
yeah no and without spoiling for people
there's a great scene that will be in
the film between you and finnerty
and it's really great performance by you
as his character of pat
and what i wonder watching a performance
like that because it is
you know another role here this mother
in it that's has some words of wisdom
and do you ever like then go back and
dig into like something you took from
when you played joyce to play pat like
is there a connection there that
kind of kicks in or is it it's totally
separate
you know it's interesting because i was
thinking about it the other day it just
it all felt so perfect that
i didn't have to think about it much but
i realized later
that i reached back a lot to my mom
because
she grew up in a totally different time
where
uh you know i was i was really young
when the whole
women's liberation movement first came
in the 70s
and i've been looking back on that time
and thinking what you know i always
think of what that time was for me
and i started thinking about what it was
like for my mother
and i realized that my mother didn't
have the opportunities that i had
right and i know she would have wanted
them desperately
i mean if my mother could have lived
differently she'd have been down in
greenwich village hanging out with poets
and artists and
all that and instead she was stuck in
the suburbs somewhere so it really made
me think a lot about that
the missed opportunity that so many
women had
and you know infinity's film you think
about the fact that they're still
in our generation there's still women
out there
who who are happy with their lives but
think wow it's different now
you you go for it you've got it's one
shot
to do it go do it and you know i feel
that way
about my daughter oh yeah she's gonna go
wand yeah so it's kind of this really
passing on you know there's never been a
better time to be a woman
oh absolutely the world and that's
amazing
yeah it really is something and you're
such
a great actress and your inspiration for
so many upcoming actresses
and i wonder with all this wisdom you
have in the field that you are a vet of
this
that did you ever like consider going
into
writing or directing is that something
that you're
kind of lean towards it all are you
really just focused on acting
no i'm i'm actually
feel like life is so
short and i have so many interests that
you know i just take each chapter as it
comes i i really love
photography um i love portraiture and i
love
documenting things so uh i live in this
really small village
and so i've been taking photographs here
for
like 22 years so wow uh
yeah so there's this real passage of
time
and what is so fascinating to me is that
you take a picture
even a snapshot that doesn't seem like
anything it's just normal life you know
like what's interesting about it
you come back to it 20 years later and
you know realize that that's a moment in
the past and it's a window on to the
past
there was a german photographer i wish i
could remember his name i was really
inspired by his work he did these uh he
had a
a big exhibit at the met and he
he did these huge portraits with a like
an 8x10
um you know old-fashioned kind of camera
and he did them life-size and he did
families and landscapes and then he had
a small
uh room next to that where he had just
taken
pictures of streets in germany right
in like the 60s and there was like no
one in them they were just
a shot of a street i mean people must
have gone
yeah okay it's a shadow street real good
part here
when it shows up in the exhibit and
you're looking at this piece of history
so
i've been thrilled to kind of document
this village
and uh you know watch because there's a
lot of the old way here
and when the older generation dies out
that way is gone
sure so uh you know so
that's really exciting yeah and i i i
guess is there like a bittersweet thing
having that's been like a crazy year and
a half right now with
quarantining and corona and but is there
have you found more time to like fill
that time with doing things like you
love like photography and
kind of like finding that other creative
side that you have
you can't really go out separately
a lot of photos of your house but it's a
good
time to edit it's a really good game
okay there you go silver lining
the winter of editing photographs you
know yeah
you always say come on time i don't have
time i've done well we got time now to
do everything
yeah i love that and
no what were you gonna say oh i was just
gonna say you know i really
am so i feel so positive about the
vaccine i can't wait
to get mine and i think that it will
eventually
uh really turn this around so uh if
you've got
any photos to edit you should do it now
you know there's a real hope coming in
the summer we can go back outside
and by the fall there will be a lot of
people vaccinated and you know life will
will start to change it won't come back
but
i just like i want to particularly get
out there the message of hope because i
think there really is a lot of hope
right now
no that's that's great to hear that just
made me feel really good too
and um yeah and now kind of shifting
gears a bit
you know you're so embraced in this die
hard buffy community
and it's cool because then you get when
you get that
as an actress which you've experienced
you get to go to comic cons and people
still want to get
signatures photographs you never you
never fade away you're always in their
hearts and so
now do you ever get sick of it or do you
still embrace it like do you
or do you roll your eyes hearing like a
buffy again like or do you always feel
that
i i feel so incredibly blessed
because when you're a theater actor
which i don't do anymore i'm
way too anxious um but when you're a
theater actor you have this
intimate conversation with an audience
you know every night's different it's
palpable the connection
and the life of it but when you do
film and i really love the intimacy of
doing film
but you don't see your audience so to
get to have done something
and then go and meet the people
who were touched by what you did
i mean that is it's not only fun
it's an honor it really is an honor and
it makes you feel
so great that you did something
that you were able to you had the
opportunity to do something in your life
that reached people's hearts i mean
that's just
that's for me that's the whole point of
my
attraction to the theater was that yeah
that's
awesome to hear and i'm sure buffy fans
are gonna love hearing that my sister
is a die-hard buffy fan i grew up in a
house or all i was playing was buffy in
the background all the time
and i would watch episodes from that
view and it was always great and
she always praised how great you were
and um
yeah it's just i think that that's
really cool that you embrace this i feel
like some people sometimes people act
they're too good to even acknowledge a
role that people love they played and i
think that's something that's
really awesome and humble about you in
particular
um now joyce do you
like watch tv and films a lot yourself
like what
are you binging tv during this are you
more like a reader like what are you
trying to do to pass time
oh um i love to read
um no i
i mean my parents didn't let us watch
television when i was little
we could only watch like four hours a
week and so i was a huge reader so it's
like really
when i do start to stream things i get
totally into it
okay but my impulse
is always to pick up a book
right and every day people go i saw this
it was incredible i thought that and i'm
like oh
i got the whole list of what i want to
watch
and whenever i do i love it but it's
just like at the end of the day
i like to pick up a book i know i love
it and readers it's really embarrassing
no no i love reading too and it's i
think people forget how good reading is
if you don't keep doing it you know like
you gotta just fall into just turning
the tv on but you forget
um yeah no i've been rereading john le
carr since he
also a recently i love to read him when
i was younger so
uh i've been rereading him these days
i love that i have watched anything okay
if you get it in the us i think it's
called
i think it's criminal germany criminal
spain criminal yes
yes i i watched that and i thought that
was amazing it was like a theater
performance
it has the same set it was so
different the cultural thing and i
actually actually i have a friend who's
german here
and he suggested it so i started with uh
the the german one yeah i didn't really
the lead character and i thought now i
know martin really loved this so i
switched it back to the german language
and read the subtitles totally different
i fell in love with them
anyway yeah that's the trick um
now you know before i let you go when
you're doing this film
uh before during after as pat do
you you've been in the game for such a
long time now do you still
have the same love for being on set and
acting as you did when you started
oh yeah oh yeah i mean acting is just
putting yourself in imaginary
circumstances
and you know everything is so heightened
you know every day we all have the
drudgery
well for me anyway going to the grocery
store you know all that
normal everyday stuff and everything
gets pushed
aside and it's just about your
connection
in these given circumstances with
another human being and that
you know it's a constant reminder that
that's really
that's the whole point of all of this
life that you have
absolutely and i mean it's always a joy
to keep
watching you i i'm so excited every time
i see your cast in something
uh so anyone who is a huge fan of
christine you're gonna love this film
it's before during after it's out today
on demand
um you can get it basically anywhere you
streaming on demand things
and christine is there anything else
you'd like to plug besides this movie
no no i just want everybody to to watch
this movie because i think it's
really really fantastic and great
all kinds of great messages in it and
it's also funny and charming
and uh the kind of movies that that
women are making today
absolutely you heard it from her
yourself check out this film christine
thank you so much for joining me today
and i hope to talk to you on your next
project
oh thank you for having me